so i'm thinking we're going to do a lot
of seed and i've been doing almost uh
probably half of what i've been doing
over the past year and a half as an
angel has been seed we have such great
companies and folks on the pod and in
the ecosystem
i've also been doing some a's b's c's
you know just like small checks
personally participating i'm thinking
with some great opportunities for that
for the fund
too do you what do you do when you see
stuff like that
we are doing increasingly serious a's
and series b is when we can get into
them
and so we'll do a 50. we'll do a new
investment in a 50 to
200 million dollar round it has happened
that's not our bread and butter though
i think what i learned over my 10 year
journey which you're basically starting
exactly where i started
which is you got a podcast you got the
audience you got the brand
what i quickly realized was the amount
of work it takes to put in 25 or 50k
is the same amount of work as putting in
3 million yeah
and the amount of work you're going to
put into it over time is going to be the
same so the quicker you can get to
a larger dollar amount put in and to 10
to 20
ownership in the winners the better
you're gonna do and when i went out
with my second fund and my third fund to
be
with the top top lps in the world
literally the top endowments
i got meetings with every single one in
their office with the top person because
i got a
good brand and i was able to you know
get those intros etc
the thing they obsessed over was my
ownership percentage of me being a solo
gp
and i told them like i'm gonna be a solo
gp so if you don't like that
what if you get hit by a car i'm like
the fun wraps up that's it
and a lot of people passed most people
passed obviously
and they couldn't get their head around
the solo gp thing and i was like that's
fine i don't need you what year was this
this would be 2016. okay
yeah that was just a weird beast they
couldn't understand and the pioneer i
think is the right
okay sure yeah you know not for me to
say but if you were yeah of course like
for me
it's not for me to say but sure yeah
we'll see
no it never reminds me of the scene and
uh get him to the greek
where they're like calling russell
brad's character he's yeah he was going
for with this african child
music video and this theme album like a
jesus like an electric jesus i mean it's
not for me to say i'm jesus but
it sort of basically compares himself to
jesus oh he's so funny absolutely
no self-awareness yeah as a rock star it
was pretty great
um but that was my big learning and then
they were like what's your fault
all they wanted to know about was pro
rada
follow-on et cetera nice these are the
large institutional lps
and the reason they're asking that ben
is what
why are they asking that question at the
end of the day this is
not just a hits driven business this is
like a grand slam driven business
and so to the extent that you are in one
of the few companies that will
matter this decade on an enduring global
scale
it's about owning as much of those
companies as you possibly can
100 correct they believe
they don't believe in spray and pray
they believe in
hitting an outlier the grand slam of
grand slams
and 10xing on that so
that's how they make money is when they
get into an uber whatsoever whatever
they're in a fund that gets into one of
those with a meaningful percentage
that actually moves you're dealing with
so much capital you're the harvard
endowment you've got 50 billion under
management like you need a lot
to move the needle i think a lot of them
are moving to a minimum of a 50 million
dollar check size
for funds that's like they're tiny and i
was doing a 44 million i did a 44
million dollar fund for a third fund
and then i realized like i don't really
need them anymore because i can email my
syndicate with a 300 members
and have whatever 20 30 40 million
dollar fund popped up without doing any
meetings
and then every time we do a syndicate
deal it does five times whatever the
funds investment was
so we did 12 syndicate deals in june
we're on track to do 150 investments
this year and put over 100 million to
work
so even though i have a 44 million
dollar fund i'm actually putting 100
million to work which is like being a gp
with a
three hundred now are you leading
in almost things that you're doing
things down most things or
leading co-leading is probably the
biggest thing
that's the big question i have we're
gonna have to see how things evolve i've
been i was
an institutional vc for over a decade
all i did was lead and it's been so nice
not leading
and following and so the strategy here
is follow
and we'll see how that goes what you
really want to do is hit one
and then offer it to your help get a
bigger allocation in all cases so you
find one you love you're putting 50k in
ask them if they would be okay with you
syndicating to your top lps and
friends another 250 and see what they
say yeah uh i did that for
calm and exactly those numbers it was
the first dll on angel list from a
syndicate was com
and that was my first syndicate and i
put 50k in the synagogue came in for 328
000.
oh 378 000. what six percent of calm com
two billion plus return it's 120 billion
dollar
position it's the biggest return we did
a little pro rata
but we actually were able to sell some
in secondary twice
along that journey to book some wins so
we still have 80 of our shares
and it's the biggest return in the
history of angelus although because
angelus and i don't have a good
relationship anymore
they never talk about that i think but i
have the number one
syndicate in the world no longer an
angelus and i have the number one return
in the history evangelist no return
comes anywhere close to calm we're not
saying you're jesus
but i'm not saying jesus it's not for me
to say but and you should get on the spv
train immediately and say
if i could come up with 20 more people
who put in 20k would you be up for that
and just start that now because you're
eventually going to get there and you're
and everybody's going to want you to put
more money in and dave and rosenthal is
a brand
they're going to want you to have more
on the cap table just give
the founders what they want give your
lps what they want
and what happens if you have a comm and
you put 50k in from your fund
great it goes 400 x it becomes a 20
million position whatever it is
fantastic but you could have put the
other right 328 000 in
and that goes 400 x and then you got
another 100 million behind it in returns
that's what you're going for here we had
uh ho nam from alto's ventures on for a
special episode
acquired what two months ago david and
ho has this
perspective where altos is unique in
this way
his comment is seed investing is the
greatest discovery mechanism
of all time they really
like it's not a secret but really their
strategy is actually they're a growth
investor
but they only growth invest in their own
fund and their seed their fund their
early stage first check
exists as a discovery mechanism to be
able to better evaluate and better
underwrite companies than the market
could
so they know when to pile the huge
dollars in correct
information advantage way 100 you cannot
trade
on insider information in public markets
and that's
all we trade on in private private
correct yep like
literally everything is insider trading
in a private market
and the funny thing about the altos
story and ho and his partners
is you would think like it's so smart
and it's what we do
and you would think the institutional lp
community would love it it took them
decades to get the institutional lp
community comfortable with what they're
doing to your point you know jason about
their
even if something makes sense and it's
logical if it's different
than the way things are classically done
it's very difficult to get people on
board because
it's new it's it's unproven it might be
better but
i do know the other thing works maybe
not perfectly but it works so i'm gonna
keep doing the other thing
all around the world tech companies are
innovating and
driving returns for investors our crowd
analyzes tech companies across the
global private market
selects the ones with the greatest
growth potential and they bring them to
you
from personalized medicine to cyber
security to robotics to quantum
computing
and more in state of the art labs
startup garages or
anywhere in between our crowd is
identifying innovators
so you can invest when growth potential
is greatest
early just like me our crowds accredited
investors have already invested
over one billion dollars in growing tech
companies
and many of their members have benefited
from their 46
ipos or exits now you can truly
diversify your portfolio by investing
early in innovative private companies at
our crowd
join the fastest growing venture capital
investment community at
ourcrowd.com twist that's ourcrowd.com
twist to sign up for free